you may want to tell the audience your
hot sauce story because i know you're
not a fan of hot sauce
so uh
you know first off they duck your head
into some seltzer water until you just
and when you inhale it just explodes
your head
and then they beat you and
and after some days and you they could
took other people out of the and you
could hear them beating and crying and
beating them
and i was black and blue but it was no
more than a good fight you would have it
wouldn't bother me that bad
but they took me out naked and chained
me up and buttered my bum
and then they filled it full of hot
chili peppers holy moly
and i did talk ugly
i thought if i'll ever find you did that
ever like every time you go to a
restaurant and they said would you like
some hot sauce that i completely mess
with you for the rest of your life or no
i'm good on the hot sauce yeah you leave
it alone
but there's a little more to it then
then they hung a dead man in the cell
with me
and it was just a little cell in july
and it was really hot
and the man was frozen and he was
wrapped in strips of newspaper like a
mummy
and
after a while the formaldehyde started
to melt and looked like he was crying
hanging on the meat hook and he's opened
up so i could see his liver
and then the fluids started running out
of him went on the went on the floor and
up the place was not even six foot
square
and i put my face under the door so i
could breathe
and as i breathe the fresh air i went to
sleep and then i'm also breathing that
fluid that was in him and i had pink
flying pigs so i know where walt disney
got his ideas from
and when i came to i didn't know which
was real and which was a dream
so this this is the first time you were
arrested yeah and all these stories are
happening in mexico
yes correct so you haven't gotten
involved in colombia
many years i didn't get okay
so you're in jail the hot sauce story
the dead man in the cell
are you this like right now you're just
like this happy go lucky like zero
percent do i feel
drug smug smuggler criminal vibe out of
you whatsoever it's very apparent how
likable you are
or do you have the same demeanor at that
time of your life or oh no i memorized
his face and i was hoping to look him up
one day
so you're being serious
oh probably not but yeah i mean you just
do you're thinking that i'm doing that
to you certainly what you should be
saying about his personality now you've
interviewed countless amounts of
uh let's just call them illegal
entrepreneurs yeah
his personality is not very common for
that type of that's a strength though
that's that's a very big strength
because you're you know when when you're
the guy
that it comes across as being harmless
he couldn't harm anybody that's the most
powerful guy in the room really oh my
god because they're so tight
i'm listening to him all i'm thinking
about his usual suspect yeah and all the
stories i'm like where's he picking up
i'm looking behind me thinking some of
this stuff is coming but obviously
you're a great storyteller and you know
that you're a wonderful storyteller but
so at this point
has the jail time have these experiences
99 percent of people if they had that
hot sauce experience the the the the
that you had not hot salad i keep saying
hot sauce the experience that you had
they're probably like you know what babe
i think i'm done yeah i'm going to go
back to redondo let's go back to you
know and just kind of hang out why keep
coming back to it especially that close
call
i don't know it didn't it didn't you
know when it was out the
um the the people that
where i was shot down for the load they
i had paid them 17 dollars so they gave
them money after a month or so i got the
word out
and uh
my wife came down and was trying oh oh
boy i mean she can tell the story about
going between those sales and visiting
me and the vis-a-vis day that's
where you have the little shacks you can
jack up with you with your woman in the
courtyard oh my gosh
so she's just walking straight with her
basket for food and them reaching each
side with her hands out
but anyway somebody come and pay the 17
000
and i was taken out the back door of the
jail
and put into
a brand new pickup with a horse's head
on it and taken to the bank and the
banker told me because he spoke english
that
this joaquin has paid them 17 000
roberto roberts has paid somebody in the
jail to get you out now that that's paid
for
and so when i caught that airplane it
was the fourth of july in 1974
and when them wheels came up i thought
before they really did get out of there
at that time how much money you have in
the bank
how much cash you got in the bank this
is 74. maybe half a million dollars half
a million dollars 74 half a million
dollars like four million dollars today
three million dollars money that you
have got to retire but but did you but
this this story was prompted based on
when i asked you a question about the
firefighters the co-workers i don't know
what what prompted you telling that
story because what i was trying to find
out is you're still a firefighter in
redondo beach did the firefighters start
realizing why is this guy pulling up in
a cadillac what's he doing did they
start asking questions that they started
reporting was there an investigation or
no they played it cool i know that there
was one one fireman there that went to
the police and went to the dea i read
read that transcripts
so uh so one guy went one guy did that
do anything did that need to do anything
or no i thought and and i really thought
for all those years they had to catch
you
and they never did catch me
how long in u.s until they caught you
from 1973 oh they never did catch me i
was
for 12 years
i was until 1982
before they arrested me and they charged
me with continuing criminal enterprise
i was number 41 that was ever charged
with that horrible
charge it's titled 21 841 called
continuing criminal enterprise and you
have to manage three organizations with
five people in each organization and it
carries up to life in prison
and while john gotti was number 42
again you were 41 he was 42. yes and he
died in there i gave up the money
and
they dropped that charge and they gave
me um i think i
choose any two marijuana charges and and
uh income tax and i got a total of 35
years with only five year sentence and
20 and 30 years of probation parole
so i got out after a couple of two and a
half years so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]
you